you know one of the things that was sort
of a surprise for me in education so I
prep school and Stanford and
undergraduate and all of that and then
the I was gonna be I was supposed to go
on to graduate school in biology because
I did okay in biology and then but I've
been at ROTC so it was gonna be active
duty as a army officer and I could have
cut that short and done' hit with some
kind of doc and postdoc and all that
stuff but I really didn't want and so I
did two years in the Army active duty
where I learned about training and
training blew my mind it was this you
know total equality of outcomes
situation where you will jump out of an
airplane five times at the end of the
ceremony of course whether you like it
or not whether you do the homework or
not that's what's going to happen and
insistence on outcome and then just the
forcing of it and I saw the quality of
teaching often by black sergeants of
just things like how to Downton you know
how to do a parachute landing fall and
things like that was just outstanding it
was it was they done it a million times
and you could say well they're really
tired of it no they're really good at it
and and the the training just knocked me
out and it was the most important thing
many important things I think I learned
in the military is that that kind of
focus on just getting it right is an
amazing thing to impart is that part of
what is going on with your courses do
you think yeah you know the central
thesis is right now we're living in a
world if I asked to any of us you know
what percentage of the population you
think is capable of contributing to
cancer research or starting the next
Google or or you know writing the next
novel most of us will say well today
it's one percent maybe maybe with the
great education system it's five percent
but I think that's because we have some
blinders on on what's possible it's
based on our experiences where we would
go through the system work working in
lockstep we're all accumulate elapsed
because we're all being pushed along at
the same rate and at some point we see a
lot of kids hit a wall in algebra class
not because they're not bright not
because algebra is difficult it's
because they had some gap
in unit conversion or how's my wall
calculus the wall and it's usually gaps
in algebra on it you don't even know it
or physics and it's gaps in calculus and
we are seeing more and more that if
these kids can fill in these gaps that's
what's keeping so it's really it's a you
know I'm starting to get more and more
convinced it's not just 5% or 10% who
can do these kind of be members of the
creative class so it's a week but I
think it'll be 40 or 50 or 60 or maybe
100% and it's almost an imperative that
it does get to that world because you
know we see what's happening with
automation and and the need for physical
labor as much in a lot of industries or
even information processing and you know
I couldn't imagine it we need to go to
the Star Trek reality where everyone is
a Explorer a researcher a scientist an
artist of some kind